[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue chez les girafes ont
donc on est à sainte marie la convenance
quelques jours avant le départ pour
paris c'est les derniers préparatifs
pour peggy depuis plusieurs années elle
peaufine ses recettes
et cette année elle participe au
concours général agricole du ministère
de l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
les produits qui vont être présentés au
concours général agricole
ils sont importants lors on a une
recette qu'on a déjà depuis quelques
années donc
et cette année en fait de nouveaux
produits ont été inscrits au concours
général donc des nouveaux parfums et du
coup bah ça nous permet d'enfin
présenter un des parfums typique de la
réunion dont on a choisi le goyavier
basilicate
c'est la première fois qu'elle sera
présente à paris un moment important
pour l'avenir de sa petite entreprise
déjà ça me permet d'être en contact avec
les partenaires les des autres artisans
des autres agriculteurs qui viennent sur
sur cette manifestation
donc déjà au coeur de la réunion aussi
de pouvoir aller rencontrer nos futurs
clients
[Musique]
voilà plusieurs jours que des milliers
de visiteurs parcourent les allées de
cet événement international
alors comment choisir les bons produits
avec autant d'exposants ce concours
général agricole peut faire la
différence
[Applaudissements]
les personnes et c'est aujourd'hui les
résultats du concours général
de repartir sur la médaille que dans les
dom on a il ya que la réunion qui a eu
des médailles sur les confitures et on
en a trois sur les confiturier de la
réunion donc c'est quand même une fierté
pour toute l'équipe
[Musique]
un moment difficile pour certains et en
jouer pour d'autres car cette médaille
récompense les années de travail
elle mérite sa médaille
empli de douceur et d'arrogance douceur
du goyavier l'arrogance du fruit de la
passion c'est le résultat de
de longues années de travail de
recherche et de
et de passion aussi ça va nous ouvrir
des portes sur les grandes épiceries à
paris dans le monde
on va être classée dans les meilleurs
produits de france donc c'est une belle
satisfaction
sa distribution et sa baignoire
bra kanon paca
prenez note que ma place il faut faut
travailler pour remettre chose remettre
en question plusieurs fois j'avais
considéré que ce qu'on a fait
il ya toujours des conséquences sur les
ventes dans le sens où ça va toujours
inciter le client à aller goûter le
produit est pour nous on sait qu'on a
fait un bon produit donc une fois qu'ils
aient goûté il est vendu le dire la
vanilleraie de la réunion comptant
connais que la vanille est né à la
réunion avec son procédé de fécondation
qui a été découvert chez nous pour dans
la même catégorie
medal d'europe 1 allez on
le nom à la coopérative on est à 150
petits producteurs qui cultivent de la
venue en se voir avec mis au milieu
forestier ou vanille naturelle sans
produits phytos en engraissant diamant
avec tout le savons fait transformation
de la réunion et avec ça va à la recette
c'est la patience et le travail d une
opération pour notre île et de bonnes
perspectives pour l'avenir porter les
réunionnais vers l'épanouissement de
leur projet est une des missions du
département de narino mais vraiment
réunionnais dans l'âme on est fort on
est solidaires etc en fait la réunion
pigalle forcément ce sont nos 23
exposants
ce sont les institutionnels qui portent
dans leur coeur
cette récompense même si de nombreux
chantiers vont occuper l'avenir
cette respiration positive donne un peu
d'énergie pour demain
[Musique]